hey guys I'm Greg and I'm John so we
just came back from a super late showing
of home but super late show super late
Chevy
q forever every got a super late show
every o'clock
Soylent and before the movie started we
went on IMAX and a couple of really cool
things happen we went on we did the
convey our a Universal CityWalk yeah we
did we put on our like headsets and
headphones yeah get three six it was
pretty cool it's pretty [ __ ] sweet
yeah and beyond that there was something
super awesome happened that I didn't
catch an article about I don't know if
it was officially announced I didn't
hear anything about it
they showed no one for his films he
likes he tends to do when he shoots
films with IMAX cameras he tends to do
trailers for IMAX where they show you
like five to seven minutes of the movie
yeah it seems like with the last couple
it's just been the first scene yeah
either really wasn't that amazing I
don't think yeah I mean I didn't know
for sure but didn't seem like the first
yeah they ship they showed a few minutes
of a lot of IMAX moments of Dunkirk like
a full scene and if you guys have seen
our trailer reactions or reviews before
I've been a little hesitant towards the
movie I've been on like I don't quite
see what's unique about it out quite
feel what's really going to make this an
experience
you know and like I don't even feel a
nolan touch to it
that all dropped completely alleviated
for me when i saw this like few minutes
of footage yay they completely Mego I
got out I gotta go watch this movie like
this is amazing yeah that that that
seemed like over took me out a few
minutes like I was very responsive which
is that it yeah I really that's the
thing like it clicked for me this time
about part of the magic for me about
seeing something in that much of an
immersive IMAX frame yeah it's like
things actually look you know like when
you're sitting on screen people look a
little smaller even though it's a huge
screen like I know still look kind of at
a scale and like when you're
iMacs and with the Schatzi choses you
feel like your euro among people like
totally especially there's some there's
that really famous crowd shot you know
where they're all in the bridge and they
woke up and they all duck down but it's
not all in one long time to take they
cut back and forth yeah a little I like
once but like in that moment that moment
when you see from their perspective I'm
on people and like it really is a mercy
no you felt that it's weird it's just a
few minutes you felt like you were in
that time period
yeah you know like we await these types
of soldiers would react at this
particular time because another line you
guys aren't probably available watches I
don't know if they're going to release
this on YouTube
I know with the Dark Knight film they
didn't release any of those on YouTube
who is only for people who went to see a
movie and IMAX where they would show it
but in walk you through it a little bit
without giving the whole thing away they
they have their cutting back and forth
them two main things there's this guy
who's this one dude it has another guy
on a gurney and the guys holding other
guy behind me that's like fight through
a crowd they're trying to get across a
bridge and it's like surprisingly really
intense and well yeah that's also
intercutting with Tom Hardy is trying to
shoot them like tracking out of E and
like an airborne Delphi yeah good ready
the enemy is on one of his friends yeah
who's in the air as well and Tom Hardy's
trying to shoot down the guy but because
of the time period it's and what made it
so unique and special my IMAX was so
immersive with this was it wasn't like
you know an average plane fighting scene
where it's like gamma karyesh law
automatic lock on it was like Tom Hardy
is this technology they had been with it
those point didn't have great accuracy
yeah it's a really time your shot than
it was like it's scary because you're
thinking the enemy could get his friend
because it's not like Tom Hardy can
easily get this guy usually in plane
sequences and movies whoever's behind
you you're usually going to be really
going to get the guy you know well yeah
it seems like you really got the central
like this this is probably the most I
have experienced the feeling of like
this kind of feels like what that would
be like I finally get how it's not just
easy to shoot your body down in an
airborne file like you see the way the
bullets curved and the details are so -
and I mean for these sequences it really
looks like they at least bid the
maneuvers even if the shots are added
only so you really get there's a lot of
strategy - yeah you're like this is not
easy and you feel you know you just feel
for everybody like that's the thing I
thought was really cool about this is
like it does transport you especially
you know the screen towers and it feels
kind of your whole field of vision and
then that moment like you really are
swept up in a war move in to see a movie
like that now yeah I know I'm really
that made me really excited for this
yeah this could be like a great war
movie perhaps there's a great pilot I
feel like that clip that few minutes we
saw really sold me on this is gonna be
like that war you know I think of you
know when people talk about how oh this
war movie really puts you there and it's
very immersive in the battle sequences
and stuff and I feel like with the way
this clip showed us it's going to be a
whole new kind of immersive experience
yes it doesn't you know I give the first
20 minutes of Saving Private Ryan or
what people kind of reference would like
putting you in the battlefield yeah yeah
yeah here and like this is going to be
different than that well it's going to
be beyond just being incredibly crazy
and violent like a hacksaw bridge one
like it well yeah I got that I got the
sense of like immersive it in the sense
that it is the right word but not the
way we normally use like it kind of
swept me up in a way where it didn't
seem like it's not it doesn't seem super
flashy I felt like using a lot of candy
to lure you it like this looks like this
dude is just filmmaking on a huge AO
right now and then like it feels kind of
I know the name Kubrick comes up you
know in discussion of Christopher Nolan
a lot but it does feel like that it does
feel like wow you're just making a war
movie as big as you wanted to make it
and it seems like it's still kind of
austere seems like it really attentive
it wants to be attentive to the realness
of the experience
yes beyond bullets and gore like just
the moments that they were showing of
the guys having to take the journey
across the bridge and fight through
crowds that way loan was really intense
when you see the treasure in it and it's
like wow you know like these there are
little stories unfolding in the context
of this kind of overall scene like
they're all in this tense moment
together what you're seeing so many
different perspectives and it is nice
like that that whole gurney sequence was
great because you feel how dizzy and
sort of we only get one shot at this man
like we got to make this work you get
the attention when they're on a bridge
is a part over the bridge is like pretty
much all gone except for this one plank
and there's like on one side of the of
that plank our soldiers the other side
of the other soldiers and everyone's
just watching them like are they gonna
cross with the green yeah and then when
they cross with the gurning it's scary
it's tough but then the crowds are
clapping like it's like what a couple
minutes I was a moment of unity amongst
these soldier I know right lane like
robbery that moment really when they all
cheered like you know fun yelling even
no matter what's happening off this
bridge we did this now like one dudes
life might just get better today a great
clip because it's so me on visual style
authenticity and character all at once
in a few minutes yes it was yeah it was
amazing and it's better than any of the
treasure like a lot of people really do
love the trailers but if you don't I'm
telling you man if you have a chance to
watch because yeah first time you guys
you might not know this not every IMAX
theater is the same and I know God's
watch them all across the world who
happen to stumble upon our videos but
like for us you went to Universal
CityWalk IMAX and there's other IMAX's
out here that are not the same size
screen as that as the one Universal
CityWalk and the thing is with real IMAX
screens most of the time when movies are
converted like we saw Kong Skull Island
it only takes up the center of this
screen yeah and no one was the first
director to go with a was an actual like
blockbuster feature film The Dark Knight
where they I'm going to shoot some
scenes with actual IMAX cameras so
instead of taking up the center it's
taking up the entire screen legit I'd
land beyond just being large the quality
of an IMAX cameras beyond anything HD
has offered us like is so crystal clear
every because that
okay huge yeah like that like the amount
of details you can capture its grand and
that's also what I've come to to
recommends like when you see 70
millimeter projected place as part of
that charm is not just in the size but
in just the amount of you feel its own
ability of the sets and things when then
the people and it makes everything
better it's like I was watching it and
it like I said it swept me up so seeing
that level of detail and just the size
of the scope like that huge square kind
of looks more like a field of vision
than a rectangle I can see is a
rectangle and so in those moments like I
felt kind of I can anticipate the chill
of the sea or you know the slipperiness
of the floor like you know it gets you
feeling really cool it's really cool so
you guys have a chance you could do what
I do for the while and watch The Dark
Knight Joker clip before I am Legend I
would just buy a ticket for I am Legend
watch the trailer for the target I'd
like to review scenes of this Dark
Knight I'm going to return my figure
yeah all right who had to watch the
movie so I did end up watching I am
Legend the first time yeah we didn't it
was you guys again alright guys well
yeah dunkers IMAX trailer reveal
complete that was [ __ ] sweet it was
better than không có island if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects John 3:2 Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram is also the social
media manager of Blum house and the real
rejects now we're going to do a Kong
Skull Island movie review